in Venezuela's capital city of Caracas a
hungry mob recently broke into a zoo to
eat a horse
one cause of the food crisis is
government currency controls that make
it very expensive to buy goods from
other countries but Venezuelans are
bypassing these restrictions using the
internet-based currency Bitcoin and
there are similar phenomenon in
neighboring countries Bitcoin is
catching on especially fast in Latin
America because it gives individuals
away around protectionism and other
destructive government policies here are
three ways that Bitcoin is promoting
economic freedom in Latin America
Bitcoin it's an alternative to using
government money and I think that's a
game changer Rodriguez Sousa is a
us-based entrepreneur who operates sur
Bitcoin which is an online marketplace
where Venezuelans buy and sell
government-issued bolivars for bitcoins
sir bitcoins monthly trade volume has
tripled in the last year alone as more
and more than his Whelan's have started
using Bitcoin an advantage of Bitcoin is
that while the government regulates and
restricts the flow of money in and out
of the country through the banking
system bitcoins circumvent the banks
because it's an internet based currency
it is not only government nobody
controls before and now a growing
community of Venezuelans are using their
bitcoins to buy food from e-commerce
sites like Amazon in walmart.com the
packages are routed to one of a handful
of miami-based Poirier services and then
shipped to Venezuela where they're
delivered to the homes of people trapped
in this starving nation when the iPhone
six went on sale in Brazil two years ago
the price was so absurdly high that it
became fodder for one of the country's
most popular late-night talk shows yeah
primera cosa people said watch fuzzy
kokujin ly phony says move now see where
ragazzo i policy league are from Amina
levar Amina pramana me camara Mina Mir
meet Rosetta - it says the explanation
for this high price is that the country
charges an import tariff on foreign
goods the runs as high as 60% their idea
of the Brazil government is like ok so
we're gonna put the high tax on apple so
apple can come to Brazil so we can
generate jobs in Brazil pretty much it
it kills Brazil but the money is
collected to the traditional financial
system today a growing number of
Brazilians are avoiding the import tax
by purchasing products like iPhones with
Bitcoin this way the government simply
has no way of knowing how much
Brazilians are spending buying goods
from abroad Bitcoin is also an effective
tool for avoiding taxes when moving
investment capital into Brazil we
actually work with some venture capital
funds some private individuals there are
investors in Brazil and once you bring
money to Brazil Thiago Caesar is the
founder and CEO bit one the company
helps clients get around to 27 and a
half percent foreign exchange tax when
bringing money into the country by using
Bitcoin but circumventing protectionist
tariffs isn't just for investors average
Brazilians traveling abroad will find
that they're automatically hit with a
six point three eight percent levy every
time they swipe a debit or credit card
many have realized if they use a Bitcoin
credit card from Zappo or a BV cash they
can escape the tax altogether it's not
illegal because there are no regulations
covering that subject in Brazil now
there is a gap and when there is a gap
not saying that it is illegal then it's
not illegal right
[Music]
starting a new business in Brazil takes
about 14 times as long as it does in the
United States and in the 2016 index of
economic freedom the country ranked at
dismal 120 second Brazilian entrepreneur
Edelson Nazario believes that bitcoin
can help solve this problem not the
currency itself but rather the database
file where transactions are recorded in
the Bitcoin network that database is
known as the blockchain and it's a
computer file with a unique architecture
that means it can never be altered or
tampered with writing information to the
blockchain is like inscribing a message
in wet cement
this incorruptible file enthusiasts
believe has the potential to fill the
void left by latin america's weak
government institutions for example in
Honduras one company's explored moving
land titles from ancient paper volumes
to the Bitcoin blockchain where citizens
of the country can verify that they
haven't been secretly altered asari au
has a similar vision for how the
blockchain can provide the trust that
sometimes missing from brazil's
government institutions system over no
que no la famosa pela sua da da da need
a key
yosh key went on potential jews of the
blockchain o Brasil mi or aleppo Jitsu
demise a popular song specifically his
idea is to use the blockchain to disrupt
Brazil's notorious notary industry which
is a major source of red tape the
government requires that Brazilians go
through a notary office to verify the
authenticity of documents like birth
certificates contracts and car titles
with every business transaction a sarios
company offers a different method for
verifying documents that eliminates the
hassle called original my the website he
built allows customers to upload
encrypted representations of their
important documents to the blockchain
then at any point in the future it's
possible to prove a documents
authenticity by checking it against the
original and the hope is that this new
system for establishing trust will
improve the country's business climate
you blockchain you think
poder de trans episode además
transparencia reserve poder de volta
prompt Rasmus de población Ivanova todo
se scenario G política Publica Antigua
[Music]